do you think history favors that
ideology or history eventually a group
of men stand up and say yeah listen
we've had enough this is not going to be
happening I do believe that in history
it's always been the same I believe it's
always been a select group of good men
who are up against evil and I think
they've always been outnumbered and it's
always been difficult and they've always
suffered all of them when I was in jail
the amount of letters I got from people
and it was just names of and I'm not
comparing myself to these people this is
the letters I got of Nelson Mandela
Martin Luther King Malcolm X Muhammad
Ali everyone who is unjustly imprisoned
everyone's gone to jail because when you
stand up for something they end up
trying to put you in jail when you're a
good person trying to do good the evil
The Matrix as a whole is going to try
and throw you in jail that's what they
do that's the punishment for it and
history has always been the same it's
always been a small group of outgunned
people who stand up who are to the
detriment of themselves to principle to
allow Injustice and evil to thrive and
they stand up and they're outgunned and
they're outnumbered but they're like no
I have to tell the truth if you play a
video game and you're the good guy when
you get to the boss at the end he has
more life than you he has more hit
points and he moves faster and he's a
cheater He Cheats
it's a bad guy cheats but you still win
because you're good and that's how
that's how the battle's always been I
would love for the world to be another
way but I don't think it's ever been
that way I think if you find any time in
history it's always been the same story
and now I'm in the position where like I
said earlier what am I supposed to do am
I have I do I have a life path in which
I can genuinely help people and do I
have a life path in which I can
genuinely do some damage to the evils of
the world or am I just going to
disappear like a coward and let them lie
about me and do my time and shut up and
delete my Twitter account and just go
away you know you know how sometimes
like uh uh uh I've been in sales for
quite a while if a guy who doesn't have
any responsibilities any single he has a
30 000 a month boom he's going to Vegas
having a good time and then he doesn't
work as hard until he runs out of his
thirty thousand three months today I
gotta go make the thirty thousand again
oh my God panic I got to pay my bills
I'm beyond on the phone let me buy this
watch and make 40 Grand I'm going out
again so it's very inconsistent right
and then as you're in sales longer
you're like okay the profile of somebody
that's going to be more consistent is
not a single guy it's a guy that's
married kids homeowner and all those
three are signs of what married
commitment home homeowner commitment
responsibility kids commitment
responsibility last time we didn't talk
about your kids at this point I think
it's public video your daughter running
to me give Daddy your kiss all this
stuff everybody knows at this point do
you when you're in in jail sometimes I I
sit there and I got books on my desk I'm
like I'm like 50 books behind and I like
to read I know you don't talk about
reading a lot but I like to I'm like I'm
50 books behind but I bet if you're in a
place where you're in jail you're forced
to think you're forced to Andrew you
don't have the phone you don't have a
computer there is no emergency podcast
go away and think you're sitting there
like okay
family kids
you know what it's really all about
those decision decisions when you think
about your kids
does it influence you to say what are
you doing this you know why are you why
are you going through all this stuff
maybe you got to make some changes in in
your lifestyle and if yes in what areas
or does it say no double down even more
because I'm fighting for them and that's
a really interesting question I'll start
by saying how thoughts in jail are
different than thoughts in the outside
world because this is actually an
observation I had
in the outside world I don't think you
carry a thought for very long that you
don't want to carry you can sit and
think about something if you want to but
if you don't want to think about
something you just get your phone out
some Pops in your head oh I don't get
fun distract yourself or you get in your
laptop or you call someone or you do
something right it's not very often in
the real world no right off in the real
world you have a thought you don't want
in your head and you have nothing to
take it away you have no phone you have
no outside interaction you have nowhere
to go what a perspective you're just
stuck yeah you're stuck with that stuff
so there were times in jail where for
the first time like I have a lot of
mental control but there was the first
time ever I'm battling with my own mind
saying I don't want to think about this
and I I put another thought in the way
it kept it was on the door it was
knocking on the door all the time and
this is for weeks because there's no it
never every day is the same you never
get the inter-outside interaction and
you also what made it worse is you never
get the answer that you don't like the
open loop if you ever say to somebody
I'm gonna tell you something I'll tell
you later and it bothers them that's
what Jail's like because you might think
of something
doesn't matter what it is I won't say
what my thought was but I'll give you an
example let's say I thought when did
Constantinople fall what year
I can't just Google it I don't know so
it's stuck in your head right so if you
have this negative fault you don't know
the answer normally in life when you
want to know something you find out
you got this in your head and you're
like I can't get this out of my head so
when you have a negative thought yeah
especially if there's an open loop to it
you need to know something or you want
to know something you can't get it out
of your mind I would sit there for hours
just meditate and trying to just keep
the door closed on negative thoughts
it's really difficult it's a really
strange experience and maybe in normal
jail in Western countries where you get
to go and interact with people you can
distract yourself but I was stuck in a
room for 93 days in one room I did not
leave that was where I was I was allowed
to go to the fridge once a day which is
a three meter walk and back that is it
in my room you and Tristan are in the
same room or no at the beginning we
weren't but then we ended up in the same
room yeah
so yeah the thoughts in jail are very
pervasive and it's also a long time
maybe never maybe never in the outside
world where I had a thought in my head
for weeks and weeks and weeks and you
just satisfy the problem you fix the
issue in the real world in jail you
can't do that
so yeah family and kids and those are
the positive things that you do think
about
but
because I think of children I think of
legacy and then if you're gonna think of
your legacy why are your children you
have to think of your legacy via your
actions
and then you have to sit and by
extension go well truly truly on my
deathbed truly will I be happier if I
gave up or if I continue to tell the
truth
I'm scared of the regret of thinking you
know what I was the most famous man in
the world and every man on Earth was
listening to me and I was really making
a difference but I got scared I don't
think I can live for that I don't think
I can live as a coward I don't I feel
I'd feel like a [__] I just feel like a
whim and sometimes inside of men that's
all it takes for us to do the most
stupid things there is the idea of
feeling like a coward a man will run
into a burning building
to not be a coward if the if the
firefighter they go there's children in
there and the whole building's on fire
is like well I can't be a coward I'll
[__] it and you'll risk your life it's
something that's built inside of us
honor and pride it's something that
should be it's what they're trying to
take away from us but it's what used to
be built inside of men and I just feel
like
I can't give up I know what I'm doing is
good I know what I'm teaching is good I
know that people don't like it but I
know I'm not teaching anything that's
bad
and yeah I want my children to be happy
but I have daughters too and how do you
make sure that your daughters are secure
and have a good future well I think you
do that by building good men
how else do you do it my daughter is
mine now but she won't be mine forever
she's going to marry somebody I like the
idea of her marrying a good man with
honor and principle a man like me I
don't want to marry some idiot so they
call me a misogynist and I'm anti-woman
I'm pro-woman the best way you can
improve the lives of women is make men
better men better at being men because
when a man is a good man he's good for
all of society including women he's good
for everyone around him when he's good
at being a man
so I feel like I'm helping them as well
by extension
and it's difficult and yeah I I I I
can't say with honesty that I strongly
considered giving up it never crossed my
mind it was there for a second do I need
to do this and after like half a second
it was again I do I don't know why I
can't it doesn't make logical sense so
kids didn't influence it one way or
another kids made me want to do it kids
made you want to do it kids made me want
to do it got it I I I look up to my
father as a hero and I would hate for my
sons to look up at me and not see me as
a hero because that's how I believe you
should see your dad as a hero and I feel
like and you're not a hero without an
enemy
you're not a hero without fight my neck
is an application which allows you to
take a minute to connect with
influencers from all around the world my
name is Andrew Tate and I'm available to
speak directly to you on minute so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign
[Music]